Liran Yaacobi, thank you so much for being with me on 20 Minute Leaders.
I'm so happy to have you here.
Thank you so much. I'm really excited. I'm really honored.
When did we do Mamma Mia together?
That was seven years ago. Nine years ago.
How much? Nine years ago.
That was nine years ago. Okay.
So Mamma Mia. Then we did Legally Blonde.
We did You Can't Take It With you.
You've done dozen other productions.
But those are the ones that we did together.
I had the time of my life under your command as the Director.
And I'm so happy to have you here.
Because I'd love to spend the next 19 minutes or so
talking about theater. Talking about education.
And how does this all fit in?
And what's it’s like being a drama teacher?
Educating you know, all ages eight to 12.
So, talk to me a little bit about what do you do?
Okay. I'll start from the beginning.
I'm going to start. Next year will be my 10th year at the America International School in Israel.
I'm celebrating a decade which feels like it flew by, you know.
And it started with me teaching at the middle school and high school.
Teaching them drama and directing a play for school a year.
So, one play in the middle school and one in the high school.
Mamma Mia, Legally Blonde. Yup.
That was my first play. That was my first musical and
it's just uh-- I look back and it's just fantastic.
You ran. We were rock stars. We were a hit.
You were a hit. And it was amazing.
And I think that it's set a tone for what theater is expected
and it should be like our school ever since.
And I do my best to bring it out there every single year
and usually we do but it was such an amazing experience, you know.
So, right next to your head over here I'm gonna put now
a small thing from Mamma Mia,
and of course I'm gonna put Pepper and Tanya dancing.
And then as the years pass, I started teaching in the kindergarten.
And then I added pre-school.
And then I started working with the elementary school as well.
And it ends up that I'm teaching from pre-school three-year olds
up to 18-year olds.
What is teaching drama? How do you teach drama?
What does that mean?
Okay. I'll start from I studied acting. Okay.
I went to acting school and I learned to be a professional actor.
And, but drama is not acting.
So, what you do when you become a drama teacher
is try to teach drama as a language.
Okay. It's a means of communication.
And that's my motto.
And that's the first thing any class would hear from me
the very very start of a course.
And say to them, "You know, we're not gonna become the next Meryl Streep in our class.
We're going to be learning a language
in which we can express ourselves in a different way.
We're to communicate with one another
a platform in which we can express our feelings, emotions,
in a way that is artistic and creative
And I think that the,
you know the main focus is that I think about when I'm teaching drama
that it's a means of communication and it's creative.
It's a creative outlet in an era of technology.
In an era of screens and,
Talk to me about this. Because you know, when I went to AIS
I had half of my classes, I have my laptop open.
In some classes, I was a rebel if I had my laptop open
because some teachers don't wanted us to have notebook.
I don't think teachers anymore are have that dilemma.
I think that it's pretty much a lost battle by now.
But I think that I was very fortunate to be in a transition age
where I experienced both the physical learning,
in-group experiences. Communication in the class.
And not just one-on-one with computers.
Now I believe every first grade or almost
has a computer that their working with.
And then they come to Liran's drama class,
and their computers are aside.
Why is this importance to have this outlet
of human to human communication for you?
So first of all, they're not allowed to bring a computer to my class.
It's the first thing that I tell them like,
"You are not, I don't want you to use a computer."
For what they will use it for?
First of all, you know, there are drama teachers
that will ask of it, ask you to journal.
To write a journal about the work, or write a blog.
like creative development and stuff like that. Right.
It's really important for the thought process to write things down
because you will forget if you don't.
But then, if I do ask them to do that, I will ask them to write in a notebook.
But I do ask them to use a computer if they’re looking for music
or searching for a certain scene that we're getting some inspiration.
But as a preset, we don't come in with a computer to class.
Again, in this decade that I've been working, you're right.
I think that you were a transition age in which you guys had the privilege
of doing old school learning with a pen and a paper.
But I think today, 90% of classes will be with the use of a laptop.
Sure.
Which creates a kind of disconnect.
You know, there's a little bit of an alien in like
Again, if you are a people person, then it doesn’t matter to you.
You have a hundred screens around you, you are able to communicate. Right?
Do you see a difference in generations as years go by?
Yes. Yes, a lot.
Really. Yeah.
I feel like--
First of all, it makes me feel older because,
it makes me feel so old because I feel like you know,
I see these generations passing by and kids changing.
And you're not comprehending like how kids are evolving.
At the end of the day I'm a 90's high schooler.
You know, like I was in high school in the 90's
We didn't have computers.
We didn't have all these things
So, looking back it looks so completely different.
So, this creative outlet, I think kids are very creative.
I don’t think you can take creativity out of a child.
That’s in their DNA.
But, they take it out with themselves on their screen.
And to shut down a screen and to force a kid to look into each other’s eyes,
is one of the most awkward things.
Yeah. Yeah.
So awkward.
And I mean, I don’t know if you remember
Still awkward for me today. So, obviously as a kid,
But it is. Obviously. It's already awkward because you're a teenager.
I don't know if you remember, when Paulina sang The Winner Takes It All,
and she actually sing looking into Maor's eyes,
and, Amit not Maor.
Amit. Maor is the brother. Yeah.
And it was the hardest rehearsal, ever.
It's a four-minute song, and there's no one on stage,
And there's a spotlight on you and all you're doing is looking at that person.
So, it was awkward but it's important to learn the skill.
I learned so much about humans, and interactions, and relationships
between people through our plays.
And I have to transition that.
Because that is the most fascinating thing that I can ask you about.
The community and the family that you're building,
through these productions.
So, you're doing a high school production,
a middle school production,
and taking a group of you know, 10 to 20 students
who have a lot of other stuff going on.
They're not professional actors or actresses, or dancers or singers.
They are happy-go-lucky kids.
Some of them more nerdy. Some of them more athletic.
And you're putting them, and you're saying,
"Within a few months, we're gonna be putting up this amazing production."
Walk me through this process.
What happens from the audition to the end result?
Well I think that one of the magic of theater,
If we take out the classes, and we learn the communication and speak drama,
the productions is you know, I always tell the kids,
"Try to visualize the fact that you're taking black little letters on a white piece of paper.
And you're giving it life.
Okay. After two months there won't be a piece of paper with writing on it.
You have built life."
And for me, that's theater.
You know the expression of life.
You bring, you express relationships.
Like you said, you express what emotions are.
You express what people are thinking.
You embody a human being.
And, I think that's the process that they're going through.
I am not a director that I don't really care so much
about the position in which someone is standing on stage.
What angle they're standing at.
But what do you mean to say. What do you want from your partner?
You know, when you're saying to someone, "I love you."
What are you actually saying to them.
What's your subtext.
Are you saying, "I need you Don Amigo. I am vulnerable without you."
Are you saying, " I hate you but I need you to be here to hear me."
Or what is it that you want from your partner. Okay?
So, I'm thinking about how acting is reacting to one another.
So, if I say, "How are you Michael?"
I don't randomly throw it out there.
There's an expectation to hear an answer.
So if I poke you in the eye, I expect you to shut your eye. Right?
'Cause that acting is reacting and that what's acting is.
And you layer it out, you know step by step process.
And I think that once the kids understand that that's what you are doing,
that's when the magic comes.
‘Cause you can dress your character up.
And you can say, "Okay, my character is a unicorn.
And I'm gonna put a little horn over here."
But it doesn't mean anything if it doesn't have
the inside is not filled up with wants, and needs, and conflicts,
and obstacles, and dreams you know.
And you're trying to imagine the life of that person.
The keyword that I'm hearing here is awareness.
Because I remember for me,
spending those rehearsals and being on stage,
you have to be so aware of yourself, your surrounding
the different things that are happening.
The different changes that could take place
during the show and having to adapt to them
So, one of the things that I thought about
is going into you know, acting or being on the stage is,
Yeah, okay so you memorize, you rehearse a hundred different times.
Liran, you caught me and might scream at you a 99 of those times
until you get it right that 100th time.
Not what to do but how to express yourself.
And then you just do it, and it's automatic.
But, what we don’t notice in the five runs of Mamma Mia,
or Legally Blonde, or Can't Take It With You,
Every time is different.
The audience is different.
The people are bringing in their own life unto the stage
And I think one of the beautiful things
of having experienced a non-professional production
was that it was very hard at least for me
and from some of my friends to distinguish our personal life
from the character in the show that we're doing.
And I remember especially during Legally Blonde,
there was a lot of drama. Like high school drama going around.
And you saw how every show had a different feeling.
Had a different communications style on and off the stage.
And it made me much more aware of people and emotions.
And I think it also tell me more empathy.
So, I think that I got so much more than just
you know, taking black words and putting them on the stage.
It meant a lot to me.
So first of all, it makes me very emotional and excited
to hear that you've been nines, eights, seven years after
you've done this production, you still carry this experience with you.
And yes, absolutely agree with you.
That giving life to a character is a complete exercise on empathy.
And yes, theater is live. It's alive.
And this is what people say, you know they say,
After seeing a Broadway show,
"How can these people be doing this 700 times?"
It changes even if its miniscule.
In US, an audience member will not see the difference.
It's the way you come you know.
You might have won the lottery that morning,
or your pet might have died
And you're still bringing in this character but there's a different.
You may sing a happy song but there's a different depths to it you know.
And it's live and it's on you.
And you're reacting to an audience.
You know there are performances in which the audience,
and especially in a school, when you have, it's an international school
you might have the parents come and that 90% of them don't speak English
as a first language, and they're not laughing at the jokes.
That you thought are, "Oh my God, they're so obvious out there."
So, you deal with that as an actor.
You're having not only a relationship with your co-actor,
but also a relationship with the audience member.
Or how like a burst of laughter will immediately ignite this energy
boost of energy for the rest of the performance.
And, I think also that that's the magic of performance.
You know, and for me being able to teach kids,
and having them experienced that
is worth everything everything everything you know.
And that was my next question.
Because you know with your experience,
there's so many opportunities, of places where you can be
and things that you could do in the drama and theater world.
You choose to be an educator and spend much of your time
working with kids who've never sang and dance
spoken on stage, helping overcome public speaking fears,
helping overcome social anxiety and teaching them empathy
in circumstances that they might not have otherwise.
It sounds great but it's very hard work.
Why do you choose to do that hard work
instead of going and having fun and have [--] or any other theater?
Well, first of all to be fair, the professional acting world isn’t easy.
Like anything that is professional you know,
like I assume startups looks like fun but it's also a lot of work.
99% fail. Yeah.
Yeah. And you'll hear many Nos next to this wonderful Yesses.
that you might hear in the news. Sure.
But, I think that for me, the transition from
the professional life of an actor, director, to teaching,
you know I was thinking when we talked about
you know having this interview or this conversation,
I was thinking, "My gosh."
Like it helped me retrospect on myself a little bit.
And I remember acting school.
And acting school for me was a greenhouse of creativity.
Was I could fail miserably.
You don't even understand how many times I threw myself out there
and did the most ridiculous things because I could.
You know, because I had the ability to try and fail
and I could wake up the next morning and try again.
Okay? And that was magical for me.
And when I went out from acting school into the professional acting world,
I didn't have that anymore. I didn’t have that.
Because you go to a casting director,
and they're looking at you and
you know, what do you sell? What character are you?
They don’t want to deal with your creative outlets.
They don’t have time. It’s a business, you know.
I love that. They don’t want to deal with your creative outlets.
It's kinda true. Again, unless you are Meryl Streep.
And she's one in the generation you know.
She can do anything. She can.
Or Judy Dench.
Or you know, there are a number of privilege,
you know, God-gifted human being that can be doing that.
But most of us, No.
I'm not gonna name famous actors.
But you know, you can imagine in your mind.
That you see one movie, that you see 10 movies with the same actor.
At the end of the day, they are the same people you know.
And then I started teaching, doing activities,
And I found that creative outlet again.
For that's such a keyword you know.
I found the joy of letting my students let them fail.
And say to them, "It’s okay to try and fail fabulously."
You know, go all the way.
There's no other place we can do that.
I mean, even in sports practices, you're practicing with the team,
and even if your coach says, "Yeah, try something and fail miserably."
It's not the same. It's so competitive.
And you're always judged.
On stage, you’re not being judged.
Well, again, it's really I think depends on the experience that you have.
But I think one of my job as a teacher, as an educator,
is to create a safe zone.
When you come into the theater, and yes, no one will judge you.
Because like you, your friend Danny and Johny, will fail.
Maybe not today, but tomorrow.
And it's okay.
You will all excel at some point and you will all fail at some point.
And it's wonderful because you try things out
that you didn’t you had in you.
Maybe an accent, maybe a certain walk,
maybe a mimic in the face,
and at the end of it, you found how much gratifying it was
for them to be able to find that little something in them.
that they didn’t know that they had there.
So, what better job in life is to work with children,
And being able to see them find themselves you know.
Liran, incredible. I had a horrible fear of dancing my whole life.
And I'll never forget the day you come and say,
"Well Michael, you know the rule."
Pepper comes of in minute solo dancing on stage.
And am like, "What do you mean? What's dancing?"
And it took time. And it took tries.
And I made a fool of myself quite a few times,
And probably up until, and also in the show itself.
But looking back, every now and then I find that clip on you tube,
and I was just like, "Wow."
Like I remember how scared I was to dancing.
And here I am on stage, still horribly dancing.
Almost falling off the stage. But I'm having so much fun.
With so much confidence.
And it’s all thanks to you.
You gave me that confidence.
First of all, thank you so much.
But I do have to say to you that I remember you
you know, I can’t be in the head of a teenager because it's been a while.
But in your head, you might have felt this like,
"Oh my God, what does she want from me."
But you never showed that you know.
And again, that's another lesson in theater, an improv.
But classic improvisation is take, yes and.
Yes and. Yes and. Yes and.
And you did. And I was able to give you,
I could have cancelled the solo.
We had live music. You could have cancelled the solo.
But you said, "Yes and I'll jump from the bar. Yes."
And so you gave me,
That was so dangerous Liran.
I could have broken an ankle looking back that jump.
I know. I was young and foolish back then.
But I believe in you guys.
And I think that you felt comfortable saying yes.
Because you felt that I believed in you.
And I think that it has to go both ways.
You know you've got to trust your director.
It's true, I get exasperated and I may scream.
And I may yell and blow my brain.
I'm not gonna lie. I'm a very emotional director.
Cause I'm a perfectionist and I expect the best from myself.
So I expect the best from my kids.
Definitely.
But I think I do tried to create a trusting relationship,
in which the actor can know that he's in safe hands you know.
I love it.
And I always say to the kids, "I will not sleep for two months
to make sure that when you go on stage you are proud of what you do.
You will not go on stage feeling ashamed."
We're not doing a play just to do a play
because it says in the calendar, "Play in March."
We're doing a play because we are going to be remembering this day forever.
And thinking our past days, what a wonderful experience this was.
Liran, this is so fantastic and it's impossible to capture in 20 minutes.
The inspiration that you gave me and so many others over so many years,
and I can't believe you're finishing your 10th year
No. It's not my 10th year. I finish my nineth.
It's just as crazy. ‘Cause I remember when you came.
And I remember it was all a big startup in school.
Nobody really knew what was happening.
None of us knew what's happening.
Incredible, Liran before we leave, the hardest question.
The three words that you would use to describe yourself
Or that any actor that you worked with describe you as.
I think that the first word to mind would be Creative.
Definitely.
The other thing would be Insightful.
I have the ability to be insightful.
And I think, I don’t know if a co-actor, but as a student
I would think I am Younger or Youthful.
You know, that would be also something also that I can be relatable.
So, maybe not useful but relatable.
So, these are the three things but I mean there's more.
And not everything is good.
A 100%.
Liran, I'll add a fourth title.
I'll say educator mainly because I didn’t take a single class with you.
There’s no record of AIS or my academic record that will show
any connection between the two us.
Looking back at my 12 years of education,
If I had to choose a few things that really shaped who I am
as a thinker and as a human being,
I definitely think that our work together was a major major part of it.
If not the biggest part of it. And here I am you know.
I’m an engineer. I’m in AI.
But I’m looking back at this experiences
as the one of the most monumental in my life.
And so I like to thank you and to just know of the impact that you're doing.
And I'm taking this also as an impact that
drama teachers and theater and directors and choreographers
have all over the world on students.
And while things are moving on [--]
I hope that we are able to retain this thing.
But yeah. Thank you so much.
Thank you for being on the show.
Thank you so much Michael.
I'm so proud of the man that you've become.
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you, Liran toda raba. Bye bye.